hi there steve kaufman here today it's
uh election day in british columbia so
i've got to finish this up and go and
vote
in our provincial election
but uh today i want to talk a little bit
about a subject that i really get
interested in
and it has to do with literacy
and
i believe that that the process of of
learning a language a foreign language
has to be
related has to be very similar to the
process of learning how to read
and how to write
and i'm not an expert on literacy i
don't know about dyslexia and i don't
know about all these other
problems in the brain that prevent
people from learning how to read
i'm a little suspicious of all of that
theory
but where i want to start is
i am involved
in a
list serve which is a uh
sort of a an email service where people
exchange views on language learning and
literacy and in all of these discussions
there seems to be tremendous confusion
people talk about language learning and
english as a second language learning
and literacy all more or less at the
same time and i have trouble sorting out
when they're talking about people who
have some you know native speakers who
have an incapacity to read or read very
well in their own language as opposed to
people who read well in their own
language but can't speak english
and there's apparently a debate going on
now because
there is a funding crunch
and bear in mind that all of these are
so many of these organizations that are
involved in good causes
um
very often they're mostly made motivated
by how they can get more funding that's
the business model how do we get more
money in the door what how do we get
you know different foundations or
government to give us more money that's
obviously a major
that's keeps them going that's their
lifeblood
so they're talking about now what can we
do to get more funding so
pro literacy
which uh and i mentioned it on my blog
post here they come out with the
statement that
there's between 33 and 93 million
americans
who could benefit from a literacy
program that's huge and if you go to
their website they talk about a cost to
the economy of i don't know whether it's
literacy or poor health literacy of 238
billion dollars and and lots of good
stuff and the need for more advocacy and
donate here and how do we get more
funding
and there's another one i mentioned on
my blog post the national
coalition for literacy and there again
they're talking about advocacy and as is
so often the case with these things like
literacy which is so obviously as a good
a social good
then it gets extended to cover
other things that are considered
socially good like
social activism and
you know
the fight against hiv aids and helping
women and minorities and all these
things get wrapped up in this thing but
you know 93 million people if that's the
case out of 300 million and and
presumably i don't know where the kids
are in that equation whether they're
you know i guess some kids can improve
their literacy but in any case that's
like 40 of the population that's just
huge
uh there is no way that those even if
it's only 30 million they can't be
accommodated in any kind of a classroom
solution
and i guess my experience with language
teaching
makes me suspect that all of the efforts
that you know if you take all the money
that is raised for literacy and i i have
the impression a lot of it goes to these
organizations where people meet and they
publish websites and brochures and
promote more advocacy and run i don't
know spelling bees or you know all kinds
of activities i i suspect that it's
fairly top heavy in terms of
administration although
probably a lot of volunteers are in
there as well
but when you actually get to you know
where
the rubber hits the road as we say you
know how do you get someone who has
trouble reading
to where that person can read
comfortably
what's the technique and i suspect that
the teaching techniques in literacy are
just as
overly complicated and ineffective
as is the case with teaching language
and i suspect that the process
of becoming a good reader is probably
the same as the process of
learning another language
and i'm i'm
just looking forward to hearing all the
criticism i'm going to get you know
dyslexia and so forth but i don't
believe that 90 million americans are
dyslexic i don't believe that 30 million
americans are dyslexic
so there must be other things happening
there
i definitely do believe that kids that
grow up in an environment
where
uh they don't hear many words because
their parents don't talk about a variety
of subjects they're not discussing uh
literature and history and geography and
nature they're they're basically talking
about very limited things therefore
using a limited number of words that
those children
start school at a disadvantage because
it's more difficult to learn to read
words that you have never heard
and i think
you know
reading in a way is just
something that is written down is just a
way of recording something that was
spoken the greatest works of literature
homer and great epic poetry from you
know in chinese or indian literature or
native american or african literature
these are all
uh stories that were told and were
passed on from generation to generation
and then are eventually written down so
uh to my mind someone who is a great
storyteller let's say an illiterate
african storyteller is very literate to
me because he probably has all kinds of
words
and i'm sure that person would learn to
read very quickly so
listening and and and hearing words and
being exposed to a variety of of
circumstances and and a richer
vocabulary and deeper uh you know more
varied you know imaginative descriptions
and so forth has got to make you a
better reader i don't see how it can can
not be the case
and so i suspect that first of all a big
part of people who have trouble reading
is people haven't heard very much
and so
um you know uh it seems to me that it's
not difficult like i always go back to
link like we always say if you're
learning a foreign language don't just
read it listen to it in fact listen to
it more than you read it and if you have
heard something in a strange language
two or three or four times it's then
easier to read it because you now have a
sense of what it's about you know what
to expect so it's easier to read
i suspect as well that
people have trouble reading it's because
they don't have many words and so some
kind of a deliberate method of
increasing your word power is key
because the higher the percentage of
words that you know the easier it is to
infer the words that you don't know so
you don't need a lot of fancy techniques
about inference and analysis and
critical thinking it's just you need to
know more words then you can put more of
it together and then you can naturally
infer you know what you're missing
um
so i mean i think in fact that link
would be a tremendous tool for literacy
and i have approached
literacy canada i have approached this
uh center for applied linguistics in the
us
and others and i get the same answer all
the time it's either that because i'm a
for-profit link is for profit like we've
invested so we're so far from being for
profit doesn't matter you're for profit
so that's no good and i said yeah but
it's free you can use link for free
we're not interested we can't touch you
you're for profit we're not
no we use other people's money
other people who have made money in some
kind of a profit generating activity we
therefore pay taxes and therefore they
we get money from the government or we
have a foundation the ford foundation
who up until very recently made money
uh that is ford did
so we use those that funding but we're
not for profit so you're for profit so
we can't talk to you
or
because i haven't studied at all of
these linguistic schools and have you
know
been involved in producing peer-reviewed
academic documents with pedagogical
justifications and so forth therefore
i'm of no interest so that they simply
will not look at link and yet i'm
convinced that if you have a system
whereby you allow people to listen to a
lot of things that they find interesting
if we
provide them with a means of grading
this
listing material to their vocabulary
level
if we always provide them with a
transcript for what they're listening to
if we build in a tool
for increasing your vocabulary creating
flashcards creating statistics seeing
you know the numbers grow as your
vocabulary grows all of the things we do
in link i think would be very effective
for literacy and if
in the united states 90 million people
need help i mean some of them might
benefit from link and the vast majority
of people use link free and we really
don't mind and as a citizen of canada at
least i would like to help out if this
is such a great big social problem and
i'd have be happy to have it used in
other countries because i'm sure the
united states is not unique when it
comes to problems with literacy but
first we have to get past the advocates
the social advocates and people who are
quite frankly protecting their positions
which i guess is understandable anyway
that's my rant for today look forward to
all the criticism bye for now